everyone i talked to everyone i had
coffee with everyone i was hanging out
with i would say hey can you put money
into my movie or
do you know of anyone who would put
money into my film
can you tell us more about how you wrote
definition please yes so i was in
a ucb sketch writing class in 2015 and
every week we had to write a new sketch
so always coming up with new different
ideas and one of my sketches was
entitled spelling bee winners where are
they now which was based on my fourth
grade spelling bee experience and if you
research spelling bee winners
they are all doing amazing things they
are working for nasa they are designing
robots they are
winning the world poker tournaments
and and i just thought it would be funny
if one of these spelling bee winners
grew up to be
unsuccessful a loser living in their
mom's basement
playing video games just not doing much
with her life so that was that was the
gist of my sketch and this was four
pages long and then
i in at the end of 2016 i got into a
sundance screenwriting lab
and
i went to the screenwriting lab and it
was really inspiring and amazing and in
2017 a couple months later i decided to
go to the sundance film festival for the
first time and i went as a sundance
influencer
sundance asked me to take over their
instagram and their twitter and go to
certain events and interview people and
it was actually a great way to
experience a first sundance kind of
within the sundance family
and my friend justin chan's film
was playing there and so i went to the
premiere of
and was just completely blown away by
the film and
i cornered him at his
post party and i asked him how he got it
made and he said
i just uh
got money from my friends and family and
we just went out and made it ourselves
and i was like great that's what i'm
going to do
so i went back home after that first
sundance and started jotting down ideas
for definition please based on that
sketch that i had written
two years prior and
then throughout 2017 i worked on the
first draft in
2018 i worked on subsequent drafts of
the film
and
a question i started with that premise
of
okay what happens when a spelling bee
winner grows up to
not fulfill her potential
and i took that question and i asked
okay what would be the reasons why this
would affect her in in not taking a job
somewhere
in um moving on with her life
and and i decided to answer those
questions by oh it's her relationships
with her family with her mom with her
dad with her brother
and and her community in general
and so i incorporated those aspects into
my script
and
as
i believe at the end of 2018 i had my
shooting draft of my script and i was
ready to
either
get a production company on board to
shoot it or shoot it myself
and you approached family and friends
so
in terms of
making the movie i had gone back to
sundance in 2019 this time with hbo
and justin's next film ms purple was
premiering there
and i got out of that screening and i
was like justin has made two films in
the time that i told him that i was
gonna make my film i am disappointing
myself with not getting out there and
shooting my phone then and there i
decided i'm gonna shoot definition
please in the summer of 2019.
and so this was january 2019. as soon as
i decided i got an email
out of the blue
saying that a show that i had sold
to a studio was caught up in the merger
in the time warner merger so they were
now releasing the rights back to me
along with sending me a gigantic check
so i was like
well this is a sign because i had just
decided to shoot my film so i took that
check and put it into definition please
and i was the first money into my film
as an investor
and then i got back from sundance and i
just went
full force in raising money everyone i
talked to everyone i had coffee with
everyone i was hanging out with i would
say hey can you put money into my movie
or
do you know of anyone who would put
money into my film
and so the thing with artists and actors
in la is they don't necessarily have a
ton of money to just be willy-nilly
investing in other people's films but
they do have cousins and they do have
friends who are maybe necessarily not in
the industry
so
they want to dip their toes into the
industry
and
something that i noticed was that since
i had already put money into my film it
was easier to get other investors on
board and put money into the film
and
then we just raised all the money and we
were as we were raising the money we
were prepping to shoot
so we were
getting our crew together we were
getting our cast together and i
did not have auditions for the cast i
just texted my friends who
i knew would be right for the roles and
a lot of them
luckily said yes and
were down to come to greensburg to shoot
my little film with me and
then we got to greensburg and
we shot the film
where did you put everyone up did they
stay at your parents house no no we
actually got um an extra producer came
in at the last minute
and
we got this influx of money which was
really great and we got to put everyone
up at a hampton inn nearby
and they all had a blast it was next to
his sheets i don't know if you're from
familiar with sheets in western
pennsylvania but sheets is an mto sort
of attached to a gas station
but they make these incredible
sandwiches especially breakfast
sandwiches that i'm obsessed with called
schmisketts schmuffin schmagel's
and
just these delicious
fresh foods and
the hampton inn was walking distance
from a sheet so a lot of our cast and
crew
also got obsessed with sheets like i am
so that was really exciting but that but
what was also really
amazing about the hampton inn was it was
only about two or three years old so it
felt like a new hotel
and they had breakfast every morning and
and i really believe in taking care of
cast and crew and it just makes the
overall atmosphere of the film
uh just better and if if the cast and
crew are happy then you'll have a good
product and everyone will be working
well together and and i truly believe in
that so i was really excited to be able
to put everyone up in in a nice-ish
hotel and give them rental cars and oh
wow and fly them out and and it was
great
it's interesting because two of your
your
very important projects all came with a
found like new found money like a check
that showed up
that you weren't really expecting i just
find that interesting yeah and you know
what like sometimes when people get new
found money they spend it in different
ways they'll put a deposit on a house
they'll take a trip they'll
um
decide to start a family or what have
you and and for me my priority has
always been my work and so i there is
never any question of
i'm going to put this money back into my
work obviously